vamos a hacer unos ejercicios tenemos
que leo tiene 4500 22.08 pesos digamos
en su cuenta bancaria y hace un depósito
por otros 800 75.50 qué pasa si también
hace un retiro en efectivo por 300
cuánto dinero le quedará en su cuenta lo
que haremos es primero sumar tanto el
saldo que tiene como el depósito que
está haciendo para que después podamos
hacer el retiro y con eso tengamos el
saldo total bueno el nuevo saldo total
pensemos ahora en 4500 22.08
más el depósito que está haciendo estos
800 75.50 recuerda que tenemos decimales
eso implica que este punto ocupa estar
perfectamente alineado con el de abajo y
entonces acomodaremos las unidades de
acuerdo a la columna que corresponden en
su categoría
y los decimales ahora podemos hacer la
suma 80 es igual a 850 es igual a 5 el
punto no lo podemos olvidar 2 + 5 es
igual a 7 27 es igual a 9 5 + 8 es igual
a 13 por lo que pondremos el 3 aquí y
llevamos 11 + 4 es igual a 5 este es el
saldo que tiene al tener el depósito
hecho pero ahora haremos una resta y esa
resta nos va a implicar lo siguiente
eliminaremos o quitaremos o restaremos
estos 300 que retiro en efectivo así es
que como vemos también 300 es igual a
300.00 esto porque no tiene decimales a
como vemos el punto de los decimales y
en este caso son ceros
y el 300 dentro de las centenas decenas
y unidades ahora veamos cómo nos
funcionará esto
el 8 es más grande que el 0 por lo tanto
podremos restar el 5 es más grande que
el 0 perfecto 7 es más grande que el 0
podremos restar 9 es más grande que el 0
podemos restar 3 es más grande que el 3
bueno realmente no es más grande
simplemente es del mismo tamaño pero
para fines de la resta nos funciona y el
5 sin duda es más grande que el 0 así es
que podemos hacer nuestra resta 80 es
igual a 85 menos 8 es igual a 5
recordemos nuestro punto 7 menos 0 es
igual a 7 90 es igual a 93 menos 3 es
igual a 0 y dado que aquí tenemos un 0
este 5 bajará directamente y tendremos
que 5 mil 397 punto 58 menos 300 es
igual a 5 mil 97 punto 58 nuestra
respuesta entonces era que leo tiene en
su cuenta vamos a poner r
cuesta
pongamos el signo del pesos que en este
caso es el que utilizamos y tendrá cinco
mil 097 punto 58 pesos al final de todas
las operaciones que ha realizado
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo